hey gang welcome to the ru garbage
comedy podcast
please make sure you subscribe that way
you get the episodes as they come out
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there
and welcome back to everybody's favorite
new podcast this is
are you garbage oh yeah so show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
found out they grew up to be classy
or if they're just a big old piece of
trash i'm your host states foley coming
at you on a beautiful day
down here in aunt tooty's basement
spring has sprung down here
haven't seen her in a couple of days
starting to get a little worried
that's all i got we're concerned okay my
co-host is coming at you from right next
to me he is the ceo of ru garbage
he's really an international businessman
sure gang the next time i've been to
mexico
gang the next time you reach for a best
pal do your favor go ahead and make it a
kippy give it up for kevin james ryan
everybody
hey gang thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you review subscribe on
itunes
full video available on youtube and
those numbers are
true i think we harmonize there
uh and then also patreon.com you can
sign up to get premium content you get
bonus episodes of ayg
which i don't think people knew are
there episodes that don't get released
anywhere else
so there's like a bunch on there people
didn't know they were different episodes
yeah so there's an episode where we play
g with our moms we do milk for dinner
we do a whole bunch of [ __ ] so get on
there check it out also hard feelings
this is a uh me and foley mixing up a
little behind the curtains you know what
i mean a little bit of hr a little bit
of business everybody loves them
uh and then we play ayg with you guys
with our top tier patrons at the end of
every month that's coming up
and also we just passed a thousand today
shout out to everybody on the [ __ ]
patreon
thank you so much i'm getting another
kia
[Laughter]
one for the weekend just one to smoking
yeah
it's going to be pre-owned smoke and
eden just keep it light i like it
uh april 20th raleigh good nights in
north carolina
get some ticks and april 21st 21st
zany's nashville get some tickets for
that one
let's go chicago sold out sold out
[ __ ] three days
down to town that's what we do
nashville's down there putting us to the
screws let's go what do we do to you
guys you got the stimmy check
also right i want you to do with it go
out and enjoy yourself come see the kids
raleigh's moving the tickets and rally
are moving so if you're planning on
going get them soon i'm going to eat a
lot of barbecue in nashville you're
going to get your money back you're
coming to see us you eat a lot of
barbecue here
i got a lot of barbecue on me all right
real quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire he's the pride of the
chicago comedy scene we love him you
know him give it up for t-bone mcmuffin
toby mcmullen yeah what up t-bone
how you feeling buddy you good i'm
feeling good i'm locked in
a little rocky start on that bony we
just did i'm fired up now toby was oh
for 32 on the hard feelings episode hey
shooter shoot dawg
t-bone's got his plane tickets he's
ready to rock and roll he's got his neck
pillow on already this kid's ready to
fly oh i got my i got my little
my comfy on i got a snuggie and some
[ __ ] ugg boots let's go kids ready to
rock and roll
gang we could not be more excited to
have our incredibly special guest here
with us today one of our great pals
so happy to [ __ ] have him here he is
a very funny
actor comedian podcaster and personality
this guy does it the [ __ ] all yeah you
might have seen him in dollar store
therapist
mini mocks on comedy central bojack
horseman
on netflix get money and of course the
indie hit
timing and you know him as the co-host
of the cool against podcast
but the big question about his mind
today is he garbage i know this guy well
i say he's gonna be annoyingly classy
yeah because he's [ __ ] he does it
right he's got a set of rules that he
listens to
he's clean he knows a lot of good food a
lot of good play does it nice yeah he's
the kind of guy that takes a good
shower yeah you can tell when he comes
out of the shower he takes a nice fresh
shower
give it up for alexis guerrero come on i
am basura
yeah there's no one comes out of newark
unscathed yeah newark's a tough one you
got scars on you buddy i started my life
with scars i came out i
cut my own way out of my mind you've got
scars but you know a lot about [ __ ]
uh
how to how to handle marzano uh tomatoes
buddy i got to class it up
i got a class very classy yeah so you
yeah so also for the listener he pulled
up on like a [ __ ]
fresh [ __ ]
yeah yeah no i'm 100 new money my my
wife goes you get
five thousand dollars in your pocket you
spend 5 500. that's what you get oh man
we're back shout out to northern
boulevard
just what i've spent on dinner over the
last couple of weeks now we got a couple
of bucks coming in would [ __ ] shake
my mother's foundation
buddy i know i'm spending way too much
money that i that i don't have because
amex hit me up and said
we're making you reserved
i'm going in the centurion lounge in a
[ __ ] hoodie
i don't give a [ __ ] hey what up
businessman move over
first they asked are you okay that was
the first time all right everything all
right
you doing good you freezing these
chicken parms what are you doing
he ate him in the parking lot this kid's
got a problem um
grew up in newark yeah baby all right
the streets in newark
yeah now hold on real quick not an actor
comedian i'm a comedian
comedian that does a bunch of other [ __ ]
of course don't give me the [ __ ]
slash
i gave you the four slashes and i added
personality
for the first time i'll have you know
yeah but just out of respect for you you
didn't [ __ ] put comedian first and
i'm going to be thinking about that
forever it's going to burn it's going to
burn i like it oh he's not he's a big
this guy thinks he's a big time act but
he is an actor and he's a good one i'm
saying you
so you think that you lead i've walked
the boards every once in a while sure
we need to reinforce these boards we got
some steel girders in here
they just cast foley as the delivery
driver i played the ocean in titanic
yes having a good time
oh man you delivered that with your hack
it was so good it was so good it took
all of us half a second to be like did
he really
i didn't know i was a hobby well i
didn't mean to disrespect but i that
that's just my little list
i add personality for you thank you
because you're a mover and shaker
but you're out there you're doing a lot
you're hitting the scene i remember at
like one point in june i think
i texted you about it it was like mid
pandemic
everybody's home like sucking their
thumbs and then you show posted a clip
of you on stage somewhere
there was like 50 000 people yeah it was
some some of it was like right under the
radar of kobe
it was like right before they're like oh
yeah [ __ ] we gotta take this seriously
you were like the last weekend somewhere
it was like lollapalooza's
it was it kind of felt like that it was
we were the host for icc which is like a
huge soccer game i mean like
50 000 people it was actually 2500 but
if you asked add a couple zeros this
guy's doubling it up
um it felt like those are my cousins all
right
dude it was one of those things megan
rapino if you don't know who she is
she's like a huge soccer superstar she's
the lady the soccer player who they said
would you go to the white house she's
like i'm not going to [ __ ] white
house oh yeah right that lady so she was
supposed to make an appearance
and it was like our time to go to the
trailer we thought our like we come up
and like yeah you guys having fun
and then we go away yeah and they were
like hey uh you guys are comedians right
we're like yeah and they're like
all right mega rapino's 45 minutes late
could you uh could you just go up there
and like with a bunch of screaming
little girls
and yo we [ __ ] crushed i had no idea
like barney loser i had no idea i had
pbs energy dude i was
[ __ ] crushing singing the alphabet
song out there
killing they're all looking at christian
who can't grow a beard they're like well
he's our age right yeah
he must be an influencer that filipino
girl is cute
all right let's get in a little business
here i grew up in newark
let's go tough kid on the streets as we
said but like we also said you're a
refined guy
give us give us the whole story uh from
like birth from birth yeah let's do it
uh
single mom but grew up with my uh my
grandmother my aunt my sister in the
house
uh it was a seven bedroom in newark it
was like a damn
it was like it looked like a mansion but
like have you ever been to like bad
neighborhoods that have big houses sure
that's what it was yeah like next door
one of the cops and on the other side
were like was like a uh they did like
dog fighting in the basement nice so it
was like one of those like we were
surrounded by both worlds yeah dude it
was pretty cool so the cops would be
over there by the way
like i got 50 on that white one it was a
great neighborhood the cops used to give
us beer
through the fence they were wild
definitely on the dude newark cops
yeah back then back then yeah that crack
era in newark
this is [ __ ] newark you ever seen the
seven five or whatever it is this
buddy i watched that i was like those
were the good old days
and these cops would have like beautiful
cars pulling up all day they were
definitely
some suburbs above ground pools the
reason they were still in norcal is
because they were doing wild [ __ ] like
every all the yeah nobody like yeah
they could have moved around done their
two years and gotten the [ __ ] out but
then yeah let's hang out here yeah
they're flying on the radar a little bit
yeah
never had sideburns those guys they
always had their their their sideburn
shape that's how you knew it
was on the take crew cut they were like
don't look that clean in the photo
yeah i mean this ain't the army i uh
grew up single mom
worked she worked five jobs did you know
your dad at all i mean
kinda like we knew of him and you're
stopped by once in a while
your mom was born here as well you're
not enough generation so here we go
first generation cuban first generation
my mom went through a hard labor camp
for two years they call them
concentration camps but that sounds odd
right she went through a hard labor care
for two years to get out of cuba in cuba
in cuba if you said you wanted to leave
fidel's like hey just sign the paperwork
you can leave as soon as you do that
the armed guards arrested you put you in
the conscience before you leave yeah you
got to work for two years to pay your
debt to the state
hold but these were like guy runs a
tight ship i don't know what you want
if it does got rules i mean what do you
want from what's the break room i wish
they would have my mom's like i wish
they would have told
us the rules because maybe we wouldn't
have signed up but didn't she have to go
didn't she have to kind of uh
cool her jets somewhere when she got
here too for a little while well they
made her they were only allowed to fly
first-class round-trip tickets to spain
because spain was communist at the time
as well
okay so they lived in spain for nine
months to work and get enough money
to get to the u.s where like like
someone had to be like your contact and
say like i vouched for sure
it was easier than getting in the cellar
it was like inside baseball
someone said like yeah they're they're
my but that person happened to be in
newark like everyone else's was in miami
people like [ __ ] flip-flops i'm
wearing tim's like what the [ __ ] are we
doing
right so someone is like what the [ __ ]
yeah
somebody works like i got him my mom's
like no
that's awesome so we got [ __ ] stuck
in newark but i'm happy i'm glad i grew
up in newark because i
what i when i was a teenager i got
caught in a stolen car which is
my way of saying i had nothing to do
with it like a four year old
we're all 14. but it's like you're bar
mitzvahed
hey you're popping yourself hey you're
bris got your arm around you
see that cutlass over there that's your
present
if you can get into it are you the moyle
um so i [ __ ] my buddy pulls up in a
mercedes he's like hey let's go for a
ride i'm like okay
ten minutes late i'm like wait who's car
is this what 14.
how many baseball cards did you sell
i'm not really taking out the trash what
do you know the cops next door
um wait hold on let me ask you a
question where's your grandmother
my grandmother is back in cuba for nine
years with my uncle because he's a draft
age
but you said you you grew up in the
house with nine years later they came
really soon your mom was the first one
to come my mom my aunt and my
grandfather she wasn't pregnant with you
yet right no no she met my father here
okay the [ __ ] prick all right
[Laughter]
yeah scumbag i wish i could see him he
actually asked for my number i told my
sister to give him the number of life
support or some [ __ ] like life insurance
you refer to him as your mom's baby you
don't even say to my dad there's
marriage
was he american uh uruguayan he was from
europe uruguay yeah
but he was living here obviously he was
living in a big cuban neighborhood with
my mom and uh
well they lived before like right around
the time before they moved to newark
okay cause they got an apartment in uh
in
west new york like uh what union city
sure i got you
know bobby is from there i got you yeah
beautiful city's nice
yeah junior city as we pronounce it um
so anyway they met
they met but they like went on a couple
days they didn't get married yet
everyone's living in newark my mom's
working like you know
day and night trying to [ __ ] save up
enough money they buy a house really
cheap at the time i think it cost
like 18 000 like nothing for this house
so that's the house i grew up in
okay uh my father bounces by the time
i'm three months old okay
uh they break up because my mom catches
him cheating on her
he leaves the seven bedroom in newark
this is the seven bedroom got it so they
redid the basement that's where they
added the extra space my bedroom was the
attic growing up that's the seven
and right now it's just you your mom and
your dad the family has to come over me
my mom my sister my aunt my grandmother
and my grandfather so your mom and dad
had two kids together you
yeah i'm the second i'm the best nice oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah there was there was
another one that uh
miscarriage or whatever was born dead i
don't know
[Laughter]
stillborn that's the word i was looking
for i don't call it born dead
that's not the metaphor that's still the
best bon jovi song
it was a doctor springsteen what the
[ __ ] this one's boom dude
um best karaoke song
so yeah so it's the five of us whatever
six of us in the house
and it's like little havana like you
know try some beans every night
it's not that would your mom do working
she worked all different like
hospital-based jobs so like
uh surgical tech uh the you know the
that's pretty good though that's like a
you know it's a step below a nurse yeah
yeah she did all right um
she worked like whatever the endoscopy
and colonoscopy you know tubes up your
button down
she was like the clean she cleaned those
she worked at a doctor's office like as
a receptionist
hustler yeah she [ __ ] that's where i
get my energy from like
like i don't think unless i'm like
exhausted by the end of the night
because i did so much [ __ ] i don't think
i'm doing enough like that's
good she worked like five six jobs max
by the time i like throughout my
my youth i was 11 years old i learned
english by the time i was like nine
right so by the time i was 11 because it
was only spanish
in the house all spanish in the house
your mom speak english now she speaks
english with a heavy accent even though
she's still
she completely understands english she
could communicate for hours just
has a real thick accent she still thinks
in spanish that's like the big switch
she didn't make
so like i was like i want everyone's
wearing like cool clothes my friends got
like tims and all this other [ __ ] like i
want that stuff
strong cuban community over there for
the most part by the time i'm like
10 11 years old it's mostly dominicans
and puerto ricans okay um
a lot of a lot of caribbean black too
like grenade and
jamaican so like you know me and my
black homies we'd say waguan to them
like they weren't popping over there
it was [ __ ] out of control let me
take a couple of sternos going
good sandwiches were smacking oh my god
dude everybody's backyard smelled
different and all amazing
it was so good damn yeah
it was like an old-school italy or
something there was one african-american
family and everyone else was like
caribbean if you were black you were
caribbean like dominican puerto rico
whatever
yeah they were this was like straight-up
african-american they invited us all to
a cookout and they're like cooking like
southern black people like macaroni and
cheese and everyone's like why isn't
this spicy
it was like they were like we're not we
make amazing food what are you talking
about
i'll never forget they wrapped fried
chicken in newspaper to let it dry
and when you unrolled it it had the
print of the newspaper on it
it was the most delicious i got a ziggy
it was though we just did that with
silly putty
oh my god it was the most amazing
[ __ ] fried chicken you'll ever have
um
and it was cool so mike have a nice meal
and find out what marmaduke's
you're like middle bailey what a [ __ ]
character crunch
i mean anybody need an 88 buick
oh
[Laughter]
so like [ __ ] it was like a fun town
you don't realize it's like super
dangerous
when you're in it yeah when you're in it
you know i mean like we knew we had that
idea but like i still live my life that
way like
i don't i don't take my iphone or ipad
out on the subway like
i still live like those traits and
that's a really
fine line separation because i worked
for a guy who has a similar background
like that and i remember
like you know you know we think we're
from whatever but when you're really
from herbs
and and there's a line like that yeah
well there's just those habits like i
took money out
to like give him back and we're we were
in the west village like you know like
we're on 7th avenue like a nice part of
that
your [ __ ] money put your [ __ ]
money away you [ __ ] put money don't
pull money don't hand me money
let me tell you a quick story so i'm 12
years old i know english i just got a
job
i got money right i just got my third
job
i got fired my first day of working at a
factory when i'm 12 years old and my mom
treated it like i got
let go and we don't know my mom was like
that's not what we do
in this family it was oh wow like i got
punished i was white i couldn't carry
four pallets at a time what do you want
from me they made me go back
my mom made me go back there i got fired
on a friday i got the job on the
thursday i got fired on friday my mom
made me go back on monday and beg for my
job back there's nothing
so when the parents get involved in the
job like i had that too where i was like
my mom i told the story on this my mom
made me like call back in and girl walk
back into work and i was like devastated
yeah
my mom's like tell them you'll take less
money and i'm like i don't even know how
much i'm getting paid
like they made me fill up paperwork to
pretend i was 16. i put my social
security number was like nine
you know what i mean four
i'm like what are these dashes for is
this a phone number you know i didn't
[ __ ] know
so i got i got money in my pocket and
there's a guy
it used to be italian in my neighborhood
before the latino showed up okay and
there's a guy named dicky who was like
the mob boss in the neighborhood and
he's the one who collected like
protection money numbers all that kind
of [ __ ] and i knew he was dangerous you
know when you're a kid like
i don't care where in the world i am i
know when i'm near the projects like i
just know
they could look different they could
look like homes i know when i'm near the
project i just know it that's what we're
talking about the 80s here 80s earlier
90s 90s uh so this guy i knew he was
dangerous first of all his name was
dickie and no one made fun of him like
come on yeah
no no nobody bust your balls for it not
one person
900 pounds everybody could said he
looked good and whenever he left the
[ __ ] pizza shop or a
bodega whatever everyone was like that
whoever the owner was was like [ __ ] that
guy man yeah
like i knew something was up he's
dangerous yeah so one he always
he loved my grandfather my grandfather
was like though buddy oh my god great
pizza shops
and also whenever he walked in whatever
food he ordered that's what everyone
else ordered because i'm like that's
gotta be good
yeah like if he was like i'll take the
you know i'll take the veal the veal
cutlet everyone's like
you know i do the same [ __ ] i [ __ ]
love this guy knows what he's doing yeah
yeah you go with that guys or whatever
100 so he always respected my
grandfather we had like a green apple
tree in our backyard
and it was the sweetest [ __ ] apples
he would give the apples to a little old
italian woman because my grandfather
knew we need to be protected in this
neighborhood sure smart guy keep your
head on a swivel absolutely he
was like [ __ ] sick dude he shows up
i'm sorry he shows up with your grandmom
no my my grandfather was here with my
aunt my mom first nine years later my
grandmother and my uncle show up
uncle moves to puerto rico because he
can't stand the weather so he got you
uh so my grandfather like my bike got
stolen
when i was a kid 10 minutes late i'm not
even making it up 10 minutes later
[ __ ] one of dickie's guys is like
this should bike right we're like yeah
yeah yeah my grandpa was like
uh like he didn't know how to yeah he's
like what's the i want to get involved
he's like what's the appropriate thank
you so we don't know you a favor is
essentially what my grandfather was like
having a conversation with
i got a couple of granny smiths in the
backyard yeah you know what take the
tree
what are we doing you know what let's
just get this shovel
we got to dig up the roots
[Laughter]
quick jamaicans get over here you know
it was like uh
they were like super nervous and i was
like thank you for the bike and they're
like no you don't have a problem
they're like the apples my mom love the
apples in fact she brings over some
sausages and tomato can it was like
the the [ __ ] the guys were like my
grandpa was like please don't ever talk
to those men
so the [ __ ] dicky comes up to me i'm
with like four of my friends
he takes his fingers like a gun and he
puts it to my chest he goes give me your
[ __ ]
give me your [ __ ] money my friends
like you know when you hear your friends
leave you
you hear the silence behind you and i'm
like it's always tough when you look
left and they're not there and you look
right you're like i know they're not
going to be there
and he was just like [ __ ] you man what
the [ __ ] so i
i how old are you i'm 12 years old i
take out my wallet
and i give it to him he goes see that's
the [ __ ] problem still got his
fingers in my chest he goes that's the
[ __ ] problem
i asked you for your money now your
wallet he goes give me that so he opens
like a velcro wallet and i got money in
there i got like 20 25 how do you have a
wallet at 12. that's all right
it's got a [ __ ] job yeah yeah that's
who's got to keep it
i got a paper folded under my arm
[Laughter]
just coupons in it it's i want more one
more coffee i get a free one
so here's he takes the money out and
there's like photos of my mom and [ __ ]
you know there's like the
the library card for school and he was
like what's this and i go those are
photos and it goes nah these are papers
so he takes the wallet with the money in
his hand he folds he goes put that in
your back pocket
and he goes what's this he's like i'm
like that's money he goes this is what i
[ __ ] asked for
so he gives it to me and i go and i open
my wall he goes no no no
wallet in your back pocket money in your
front pocket he's like you put the money
in your front pocket
yeah i do it so then he goes boom give
me your [ __ ] money i go to reach my
wallet he pushes into my chest he's like
i said give me your [ __ ] money and
now one of his guys like hey dude dude
what are you doing he's [ __ ] 12 dude
he's like shut up and he's like i said
give me a [ __ ] mind he's yelling
people are watching
and i go in my pocket and i go to give
it to him he goes throw it behind me
and i throw it he goes if i'm robbing
you what am i going to do
and i'm like you're going to turn around
and grab the gun it goes i grab the
money goes and when i turn around what
are you going to do
i'm like uh he goes you're gonna [ __ ]
run so he goes
he goes now what's in your back pocket
and i'm like my wallet goes with what
i'm like my papers he goes
papers take [ __ ] weeks to get back
money you could find on the floor
he goes pick up your [ __ ] money and
don't ever do that again i just walking
by
to this day i'm not making this wow to
this day here's my money
damn and there's my wallet i know no
[ __ ] dollars ever go in my wallet
to this day like that's it he told me he
taught me that and i was like that's it
i think i'm in a bronx tale
take that sesame street yeah everyone
where are you on that one big bird
doesn't know
[ __ ] i guarantee you he got his money in
his wallet whoa
baby want to take a quick second talk
about the good time that uncle hank and
the old
kip kipparino are have it over there on
the stereo app
usually every thursday nights at nine
o'clock we're taking your questions
live on the air yeah guys it's an
awesome app you can use the link in the
description to sign up you join we get
to wet our beaks a little bit
it's a nice live q a little after party
little extension of the show good way to
for us to interact with you guys
you record your question live we play it
live we answer it live
it sounds great we get a couple hundred
people in there it's a good old time
we get trolled by some teenagers which
is fun a couple of teens hop in we mute
them real quick
boom powell stick those kids with the
iphones i love them
guys so go to stereo.com kevin ryan or
slash h foley the link is in the
description
sign up today we'll see you then now
back
to the show that's nork in like a
nutshell you know what i mean
that's like that pennsylvania what
happened to nothing like that how did he
make out was he is he okay uh
no he didn't so we found out dickie had
a bad run
yeah i was like dickie had a bad month
i found a gun in the trunk they were all
imperiales guys imperiale was like the
dude who ran all the nork
and that all started to crumble that all
started they found uh they found an
ambulance full with guns
there was like a turret attached to the
front of it and the hub yeah
those guys those i think they started
going crazy where they thought like
people were listening in on them and
probably were but not just the
government like they were afraid of
everybody
that was like a massive house over by
the park and those dudes like they went
from like
parties and you could ride your bike by
and they'd be like yeah you want some
whatever got a little dicey
no one was out there guys with like
hands by their hips it got real weird
and then all of a sudden
they all went away they were gone and
then the main restaurant in newark
moved to the mayor who ended up getting
arrested for being wildly corrupt
uh he took over the restaurant so like i
think it was like a huge power play
those guys were getting old anyway but
huge power play and everyone just
disappeared
like i remember i i know the kid whose
dad owns karibe which is like the big
bodega there
um and i said yo whatever happened to
the guys who used to come by and collect
he's like one day they just stopped
damn and i thought like power vacuum
it's like they lost the neighborhood by
that point
yeah yeah yeah yeah was that the same
mayor that was that got caught up in the
abscam thing
in the sharp james yeah yeah road his
last day in office he rode a bike
through city hall wearing a malcolm
shabazz hoodie
not a hoodie a wife beater and a hat
that's the school there [ __ ]
god what a legend that's pretty dope
riding a huffy through city hall
man and he said he said uh i won't say
the whole thing but uh one of the
reporters was like hey what do you have
to say about the people who said you
gave because he gave land to his gum
odds like to his girlfriends and he goes
he say i say [ __ ] you and he said yeah
that was one of the last things he
yelled through city hall in office
yeah he was technically still the mayor
it was just the [ __ ] best
fantastic and then cory booker came in
and we're like oh this guy's too clean
booker's a nerd he's such a [ __ ] nerd
such a nice guy i don't know about the
paper in the wallet thing
right now i bet you'd be asking for
he'll give you his money he won't even
know
you know he'll just give you his money
like listen i have venmo
take the tree holy [ __ ] all right so
what was high school like high school
was rough because all right so i get
expelled from
elementary school you got expelled i got
expelled i got expelled twice once in
elementary school once in high school
so what the [ __ ] i so the stolen card
thing was how i got expelled in
elementary school principal's car
yeah you're not apparently in newark
you're not allowed to get arrested
uh big shock uh you know the cool thing
was the guy who arrested me was partners
with one of the guys next door so he
brought me home
to the police department but my name
still made the [ __ ]
the report so when i got back to school
all the kids who really did steal the
[ __ ] car
and me were all called to the
principal's office next thing you know
i'm going to school in nutley which is
the mob town
that's where the writer for the sopranos
comes from okay martha stewart's from
there beautiful town
i end up hooking up with this girl
beautiful redhead i'm married to a
redhead now probably what started it
right beautiful redhead we go to our
house there's this [ __ ] massive photo
i mean
the size of your wall this huge like
beautiful frame like
the kind of [ __ ] you see in a mall and
you're like no one buys that [ __ ] and it
was the dad with his legs crossed all
wearing all rings in a suit
and his daughter and his wife next to
him behind the big chair
and the guy you could tell is like four
foot eight and i said what the [ __ ] is
that and she goes that's my dad
and i'm looking at i'm like i gotta get
out of here i was like
that's i'm like all the furniture is
like really ornate i can hear
meatballs being good and i'm like it's
like all my senses are telling me run
the [ __ ] you throw your money down the
hallway and take off dude
dude i got super [ __ ] nervous because
she like would oh we would like hang out
right
and uh i got super nervous i was like
yeah i don't think we should hang out
anymore
and uh she was like ah dude it's
probably because you think my dad's in
the mob that's [ __ ] that's not real
blah blah blah
like two years after high school she
were in college and i said like what
happened to and they're like oh she owns
like three tanning salons in new jersey
and i'm like
i knew it i knew it yeah
she's managing a rock club that was sure
yeah waste management could you believe
it
throwing a bag of pinkies in her house
yeah imagine they were just honestly
like yo she presses a couple local
unions every year she's great
that's like that's like our buddy chris
scopo his dad's aunt
he's like the biggest mook from queens
and i'm like oh what do you do what's
your dad do he's like
sanitation i'm like could we get any
more [ __ ] storybook mob
did you ever see uh what was that the
most dangerous year in new york or
whatever
the most dangerous year yeah there's a
guy isaac there's a guy in there the oil
the oil there's a guy their character in
their name ralph scoble which is scopo's
dad scorpio
oh it's like an uncle we don't really
know he got shot it's like he's
he got he got [ __ ] ran up on in
staten island and the dudes that hit him
hit him like i'm in like i'm [ __ ]
johnny mob over here
what part of pa you
[Laughter]
you know i met that guy's kid donnie
brasco's kid he's a film
uh film director okay that isn't donnie
brasco like he like
have something alexis is all over the
place i think you're in the mob
you said donnie baldo as far as gumpa
newark
the guy's real name is piston yeah yeah
or uh
i met his kid his kids uh his kid's a
director and the reason
i he said i made a movie and it was
called like federal
cash flow and i didn't hear him i'm like
you made a movie called fidel castro
i was like mad and he was like no yeah
it's called federal cash it's about like
uh
[ __ ] loans or whatever it's dope
it's awesome yeah we need some [ __ ]
shout out to biden
yeah that's timmy's got a hit moneybag
joe
let's get it here you guys had your toe
and everything over there in newark
buddy you know it's funny like
i you learned you live different like
i'm i meet people in new york now who
aren't from this area
and they just they don't know how to tip
right you know what i mean like
here yeah those are the things you learn
on the streets those
yeah those are just things you learn
it's not the streets yeah but like more
blue collar people
middle america tips better they know how
to take not middle america i think it's
east coast
that's 100 percent not middle about i
meant like middle class like
i've been stiff by some some lady from
wisconsin a million times and i'm
waiting tables i'm trying
to leave him eight percent eight percent
you broke my [ __ ] balls for an hour
and a half
i'm trying to say normal working people
for uh on the you know from here
yeah it's a coaster it's an eastern
seaboard thing because it's it's a very
mob thing it's like chaos you gotta hit
them with [ __ ]
i remember being like [ __ ] seven and
being like my dad just like
[ __ ] breaking dudes off with buddies
you got to do it it's just like i go oh
that's what you when i go yeah agree he
would call it greason yeah we went to
veg
this is our trash we are my dad got
remarried in vegas at the bellagio
yeah and i remember just everybody
getting dubs and then
i just picture everyone wearing jeans
and matching linen shirts
oh we did all right i had a suit but i
did wear a sweater it was just a sweater
and a jacket i look like tony's
it was that a gold chain um but he would
call greet you gotta grease them and
that's what i learned i'm like oh yeah
you got to [ __ ] everybody's got to
get everybody's got to what they're be
going sure
and all my jobs were tipping jobs
growing up you know what i mean
yeah dude i've the a new guy today i
went to the butcher shop to get uh bread
and meat and
the [ __ ] brand new guy and i was like
oh no i'll wait for vincente and he was
like oh vincente's off today he's like i
can help you what do you need
and the guy was cool he was like busting
my chops a little bit we we joked around
the cat we joked about the cat
and like midway through i was like yeah
he's gonna get a tip and i [ __ ] i
gave him 20 and he
on top of the thing after the credit
card he was like oh no you gave me the
credit card go nah it's for you
and he goes cool he was like he said
like oh and i'm like next time i go in
there
i'm not gonna have to wait for everybody
or even if i do it like i got you or
yeah give me that good you gotta check
me
yeah yeah like you pay for the better
service and all these old
fuddy-duddies with money they don't know
how to [ __ ] do that and those are the
traits that you have that i like when
when i say you know you're
you might have come from from a rough
from a rough part but
you know how to like how many guys you
know goes to the butcher shop
yeah well he's well hold on when it
comes to those specific things
he's a fruit he's a big food guy yeah
big italian
everything but it started off pete like
you're you haven't gave me my name
you got me my name and food yeah yeah so
it's like you're very he likes the
butcher
he's not going to get [ __ ] you know
he's not going to the [ __ ] shop right
to get you know
watson like he knows how to handle
himself in a deli when i get wings
when i get wings i go are these air
chilled because if not i don't want them
what does that even mean because if you
if you freeze them in water the skin
will never get crispy because it absorbs
so much water so you got to get air
chilled wings
in order to get the way that kind of
[ __ ] yeah that kind of he told me that
about uh the pizza
at uh fiero's or what's it called the
origins fiori's fiori
the reason that it's the bacon or the
the pepperoni when the sauce is exposed
to the heat it melts down
and reduces and gets more flavorful yeah
it concentrates the flavor that's the
purpose of staten island style pizza is
the sauce is exposed
so the cheese doesn't completely cover
the sauce if the cheese completely
covered the sauce the moisture would
actually settle into the crust
i know yeah yeah yeah he was yelling at
me for eating elios at the time i think
when we had disguise so let's get into
it we're like screaming at me if you had
to do a frozen pizza what are you doing
i'll go gun to your head it's going to
sound shitty i'll give you the [ __ ]
answer and then i'll give you like the
what you want to hear
the real answer is i'd probably go for
like table 87 which is in all whole
foods
it's it's made in new york and then they
vacuum sealed class
if you want to hear like you're at a
bodega that what's available
you got a seven or eight bodega i
wouldn't get frozen pizza at a boat
you're at the super you're at you're
trying to say they don't have options
you don't have options right
i'm going to shop right i'll go not the
french bread
but the stouffer's french bread is
lights out the right answer
i got to be honest with you it's great
but it's not to me it's just not enough
pete like i still want it to be somewhat
pizza
i see what you mean because it's on a
roll
to me it's basically sauce and cheese on
a roll that's a french bread pizza yeah
there's not even a lot of sauce on there
i'll give you this much oh you know what
i will go stopher's uh french bread and
i'll throw it in a toaster oven because
that that's how you do it
microwave come on did you see someone
start their oven and you're like what do
you think i have to
start the oven i don't have a toaster
oven you got to get a toaster
were you a toaster of a kid growing up
or a toaster i was a toaster
did you have a toaster growing up or is
it too no we didn't we never ate sliced
bread like that only for sandwiches so
we never toasted them
yeah no like i would go to my friend's
house in the morning and they'd be
eating like
two pieces of uh regular toast with like
butter butter
and i'm like what do you do wow i
remember the first time a friend of mine
we had
pieces of steak and tater tots at his
house and the mom brings out milk and i
was like you guys actually do this
i put dinners yeah i was freaking out
i'm like yo white people are crazy i'm
like
you must take the dumbest shits ever
milk with meat and tater tots eating
every part of the cow oh i have another
question i want to get to but first
do the pizza what what are you getting
which if you're in a shop right mine is
uh so it's not you're not sure
i'll probably if it's like garbage you
will okay good all right helios is where
it's at
i don't know if that's a natural you're
saying that now but you really wouldn't
do that i just wouldn't eat pizza
but he's a gun in my head what am i
going to not listen to the guy with a
gun
you're at a supermarket it's only the
frozen pizza that's the first part of
the story
i see some nickel i start listening this
guy's a [ __ ] maniac he put a gun in
my head he doesn't want money he wants
me to eat a frozen pizza buddy we're
getting some helios
i'm not even putting it on the toaster
i'm eating it cold i'll eat the
cardboard i don't give a [ __ ]
i got a very important question go ahead
it's been it's been a spot uh this one
this was the next question i was
bringing up hit him with it
uh if you're going to uh not like a deli
right you're going to like a brooklyn
bagel or like you're going to a place
that makes it
i know no no no it's not this you don't
toast it
you don't toast the bag dude that's what
i'm talking about that's what this is
why i love that i was leading the way
you did no it was no he wasn't he didn't
even ask the [ __ ] question
he wasn't i knew for another question
because he was like a real place to be
exactly real no no that's important
because you toast the bagel everywhere
else
except the place that makes it
themselves if the if the bagel's coming
out of a plastic bag you [ __ ] toast
that yes
yeah if it's at a bodega like in the
storage bin and you know they don't bake
it themselves
you got to get it toasted here's the
truth about toasting a bagel it
caramelizes the natural sugars in the
bagel
it'll win it so drop some [ __ ]
knowledge on t-bone toasting a bagel
will lift the bad bagel but we'll drop a
good baby yes to mediocre dude
all right so far that just happened this
year dude grew up in a neighborhood that
was a u.n cafeteria [ __ ] your show
dude u.n cafeteria is such a wonderful
way to talk about north noriko
it's it's the wake because walking
around
in full headdress just sitting over a
fire pit i'm like this is
that's my neighbor steve dude i refer to
him on this stuff
and you he's right it's right that's it
because if you if you have a piece of
bread that's not
that fresh you toast it you toast you
toast it like you go to other parts of
the world they call it like toast bread
they're like yeah we don't eat white you
toast white peppers sure
yeah even all the americans eat like
proper white bread
oh dude the kind of everywhere else they
toast it that wonder bread type [ __ ]
that gets stuck to the roof of your
mouth is eating the sandwich you gotta
toast it i love that yeah yeah yeah
that's pb and jason sticks in your teeth
for like three weeks what if my sandwich
is
welded in there flexible in the bag i
get nervous we don't like what are we
doing
it's kind of stiff i need i need
strength your chips on the sandwich guy
too we talked about it
he i tweeted to one day we got to
normalize the bodega putting chips on
your sandwich he goes they do it you
bring up the bag of chips
and say put these on he goes yeah for
sure it blew my mind i never thought
about it
yo throw some doritos on there hector
let's go 100
man how about this i'm gonna i'm i'm
talking to a guy now about starting like
a youtube food channel just because i
have like
all these rules of how you're supposed
to eat or not and one of them he didn't
know this that you could go to a bodega
and be like
you go get like whatever you want so i
went with him and i was like check this
out i went and got takis
and i gave it to the guy i was like yo
can i get a breakfast burrito with takis
that goes like okay
he opens it up spills it in the burrito
makes the burrito puts it in boom wraps
it up gives it to me
gives me a little bag with a little bit
of the takis left done they don't have
they're the circle ones but they look
like
they're like all the spices they're like
rolled up doritos basically they have a
lime hint to them don't they
yeah they're they're mexican uh it's
like uh tahina the spice
the cinnamon really [ __ ] good they're
great do that with eggs
fantastic and the melted cheese wraps
around it [ __ ]
he does it right he does dude i still
think about it and i don't know the
place you'll probably
be able to pinpoint it you posted a
picture of a chicken porn about seven
years ago
milano's market on the upper west side
i said well where the [ __ ] is that you
go upper west side i've never
i think about this [ __ ] city oh yeah
there was a run for a while leading
up to the pandemic where you because you
you did the pizza tour and arts
and you had ends with all these amazing
pizza places that did
italian specialties as well yeah which i
think i always say is the most
underrated food
in new york city it is a good pizza
place definitely they make a [ __ ]
great peniela vodka
or [ __ ] chicken franca most of the
time and you were somewhere and it was
like a nine
course meal of like roland teen and this
and that
that's eleanor gardens yeah chef menu
get the [ __ ]
tasting menu it's wow you got to be like
there you're there for a day and you're
sleeping for 24 hours afterwards
they feed you like an italian grandma
would like
to stop being an idiot eat all of it
yeah it's [ __ ] wild and it doesn't
stop it just keeps coming
it took me it took us three hours we sat
there for three hours eating
not like down time like more as soon as
you thought you were done with like a
bowl
they brought a different meal out it was
crazy i always have a problem being
around you because whenever we'd run
into each other the club
we would this is the comments this is we
don't even need the cameras right this
is what they've been doing
and then by 15 minutes later i'm [ __ ]
starving
the people who live above new york
comedy club on fourth street are like
these two again
dude i had a strong boy the other day
to die for but he does do it good he's
never he's never missed he he does he
he does not miss he's never you've never
given me a bad recommendation and to be
honest with you our friend mike feeney
who lives in the same neighborhood as me
he's a foodie too he's never given me a
bad rap
he's got him and i have back in the day
when he was still doing like the beard
distributor [ __ ]
he would basically drive around it was
like he would he would get paid to eat
lunch like you'd be like i'm talking to
them about beer and he would go like
great restaurants and [ __ ]
he would always hit me up and like yo i
just ate this you got to try it like him
and i would trade spots all the time
food spots all right well why we're here
why we got why we're on the [ __ ]
subject
best slice manhattan
one slice because you said manhattan
yeah it's gonna be three hours
i started this conversation with
somebody on stage that runs the light
and i still had to run in there to
[ __ ]
one one one name if you had to say if
you had to say manhattan
i think the best slice of pizza is
actually in brooklyn but if you had to
say manhattan
stars scars scars on on
orchard between hester and canal and i
used to be friends with growth we don't
get along anymore
it's still an incredible slice there's
no reason you should go anywhere else
just prepare yourself
who has beef with a pizza place we used
to be a good friend his name is scar i
don't think he's making friends
it just it was over some dumb [ __ ] and
it's one of those things where like we
both agree like
nobody it's not that serious and it's
never going to be solved
pizza seriously nobody else would have
that can i tell you something you want
to know what the beef was
his ingredients yeah he's like a pizza
nerd
yeah yeah he was saying something about
an ingredient i disagreed it became a
whole [ __ ] thing
and i was like yo you're starting to cut
corners i don't like it and became a
whole thing and it true to him i love
you scar
yeah true to his word he went back he
went back he's using great ingredients
wonderful pizza
you probably won't see me hanging out
there but go eat his pizzas you don't
talk to alexis anymore
he insulted my mozart did you ever see
pope greenwich village yeah
my favorite movie when they're when
they're sitting there talking about the
horses
cheese makers i know i know cheese you
actually don't we had him with throw
stuff
he what do you say like i forget his
family's name whatever the hunger
mozzarella
he go yeah he goes the vitellis have
never sold the duff beats around their
lives
it's such a great line i love that
[ __ ] line
cut off the next scene yeah yeah yeah
it's such a great build up that script
i could talk about that script forever
love that movie they always give you
some like [ __ ] town like local [ __ ]
and then
something bad happens right like
life-changing happens after some like
innocuous conversation see that's very
you because remember in the one scene
where they're eating lunch outside
they go to like four different places i
remake that sandwich every year and they
they go and they get the cheese from
here they get the they go
they go to joe's dairy to get the cheese
they go to pinot's meat to get the meat
and they make it they make it march on
the check on the chess table and he said
they should give you a permit to take a
[ __ ] in this yeah
the horses man you got to step your
[ __ ] fat guy this guy is
you're hanging out in the drive-through
you're walking through the drive
extra put a couple toys in that in that
uh
that happy meal it does not look super
shy i'm real good with that stuff but
i'm
on on a very garbage level like you you
you wouldn't do
we're two very different eaters yeah
yeah you know what i
we come at it from different angles
[Laughter]
how have you been handling covid because
the delivery it's just not the same
it's killing me um my wife is also a
very good cook we've been doing it yeah
she throws down
yeah i've seen on instagram she's pretty
[ __ ] great um she's also one of those
people that
has that little bit of [ __ ] jersey
knuckle dragging italian in her
that uh her family's all like hoboken
jersey city [ __ ] where if i'm like yo
this meal is amazing she's like yeah
oh is it i could [ __ ] make that yeah
and now i get like three versions
of it the next week because she's like
trying it out like she made a tiramisu
she does a fresh pasta so
she does her own coffee she makes her
own pasta everything so when i was a kid
i worked at a restaurant
this is real guinea [ __ ] we're talking
yeah oh how do i deal with it
in-house yeah yeah yeah we handle it
behind closed doors i go down to the
cheese cellar
yeah i also live above a restaurant
right when covey started he's like you
want all these clams i don't know what
to do with clams i just made a bunch of
clothes [ __ ]
i love this he delivered he just gave us
a david clams
half off act now as it gets further away
from
from the date you just doing them
different yeah by the end you're just
frying them
it was [ __ ] great but my wife so when
i grew up i worked at a restaurant and
my buddy's dad owned it it was like a
way to get us off the street uh
and he made i said to my wife like 10
years ago he made the best tiramisu i
ever had it was like a trifle like you
had to scoop it into a cup it wasn't
like you cut it like yeah
yeah yeah and i would talk about this
tiramisu like it changed my life and out
of nowhere my wife the other day goes
uh i'm i'm gonna make dessert don't eat
anything sweet i was like all right she
brought over a piece of tiramisu
i tried it was incredible she goes
better than virgil's dad she just said
it like that
she remembered 10 years later while this
part the next day i get a phone call
virgil's dad died
oh yeah just turning over in his brain
right now
i was like you heard you were stepping
out on him yeah you know you know how i
answered because
it wasn't better i was like it's
different you know it's different
it's just a different tiramisu but it
was so [ __ ] good i'm like this is my
life
i get to [ __ ] joke around about
soccer and talk about [ __ ] pizza
and at some point my wife is like this
tiramisu better because if not i'll make
another one yeah if not we'll run it
back yeah
you think i won't remix this [ __ ] that's
funny you know i met this guy 40 minutes
ago he's my new favorite guy
buddy we're going to newark get your
head dressed
take your money out of your wallet
put your keys in your [ __ ] all right
we gotta get we gotta get us some
regular questions however before we do
that i just wanna finish up the the tale
that you know kind of got us get us up
to
to date did you go to college or
anything like that yeah yeah i got
accepted into nyu for filmmaking
and yeah my mom was like i got accepted
to uh tisch for filmmaking or is it tish
whatever there yeah tish
and then i got accepted to stern for
general under the general studies
program
what'd you get on your sat that's pretty
good man i think like 12.50
damn that's not bad did you end up going
to nyu no they wouldn't give you any
money
and i was like what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you i got accepted here twice i
can't get it you know double it up
uh my mom was like you're gonna go to
school to make movies
i was like well yeah i want to be a film
director i had a class in high school in
like a shitty little high school but
they gave us like
a filmmaking class because the guy used
to work in hollywood and he was like
you're really good you should do this
and i loved it i love making this movie
um
i i just like all right i'm gonna go to
school filmmaking and my mom's like look
she sat me down she's like do whatever
you want
look you stop [ __ ] up your your life
is straight now you know what you're
doing
um don't do something that's going to
make you still live in newark
you want to get the [ __ ] out of here
she's like go go work in business and
then be the movie producer not the
director that can't find that
not checkers baby yeah and i'm like all
right and that accent that was probably
a great speech though and i wanted to be
i wanted to be a comedian like when i
was a kid and someone said like what do
you want to be when you grow up i'd
always say comedian like one point i
said calm and my mother covered my mouth
and she goes
computer science like she knew like this
kid's gonna [ __ ] yeah yeah and that's
a true story i don't tell that on a page
that's like a true story like i knew i
was gonna disappoint her but she was
like look
go to school for business and the only
school that had business and was willing
to give me money was saint peter's in
in jersey city okay that was in russia
so [ __ ] the killer peacocks killer
cox ryan cox let's go
uh where's that in jersey city they're
division one basketball but they suck
every year they're always good at the
mit yeah did you go and stay there
no i lived in newark okay my so but my
wife also got accepted
to nyu couldn't afford it went to saint
peter's and that's where we met
wow yeah there we go actually you guys
eating a long piece of spaghetti
and at the end we're like that was a
cook drink you both have notes on it
did you think that myself yeah i don't
think so do you guys know the
restaurants
they use canned tomatoes we can't come
here you know the restaurant lilia
it's like a famous restaurant brooklyn
they make their own pasta it's like
really super
end like actors and [ __ ] will hang out
there the the lady breaks up with the
with the partner and
she opens up a place called missy right
so i go to missy with another chef
friend
and they're like bringing everything out
it's like one of those meals like we
don't pay a dime like
those they're the greatest time
go eat with chefs everyone befriend a
[ __ ] chef uh so they're bringing out
all these plates and wine and the whole
nine and at the end of the night we get
up missy comes over and everyone's like
you know cause she's here and they're
like that was you know thank you so much
everyone's like thank you thank you
thank you she's like oh what'd you guys
think and they're all breaking down the
meals like same way i would and she
comes to me she's like what'd you think
and i was like
do you use laval tomato and she's like
yeah and i go
you're better than that that's all i
said what a good i like it
the lady the lady looked at me a little
pedestrian she goes
she goes the lady said missy said to the
other guy she's like is he with you and
he's like yeah i'm sorry
yeah and they're like you know one of
them is the guy who invented mike's side
honey she he's like this is my client
you got a [ __ ]
and i was like come on you better i mean
you're charging us that much money like
you're better than that for lavell
and i was like i could get you better
tomatoes if you need i know a guy
that's what i mean and she was like not
having it so that was like two three
years ago i
just talked to him it's like tony asking
arthur who does his drive who doesn't
dry clean up no this guy doesn't use
yelp because he says it to your face
yeah i love the meal like i didn't pay
attention
to the hand-in-hand combat version he
likes to feel the knife though
i'm more krav maga
dude i saw her this weekend and a buddy
of mine knows really well and i'm
walking with them and like oh are you
selling your home like they're having
like rich people conversations
and she was like hi i'm missy i was like
hey what's up i'm alexis
and through the match she's like did you
ever eat at missy and i was like
yeah she goes i changed my tomatoes yeah
i was like oh
because that could have gone real bad
that was this weekend and you're a prick
and you're an [ __ ] yeah she goes i
want to come see you perform i know
she's going to hack
oh she's going to yeah she's going to
[ __ ] she'll be waiting
for you throwing tomatoes at you all
right
let's get into some are you garbage
questions yes let's go
okay i am so excited for this i've been
waiting for this one i gotta call i got
a couple
two two three food ones and i just want
to we can hit real quick
we're gonna throw some curve balls yeah
yeah yeah we know the story yeah how do
you feel about uh
hormel pre-sliced pepperoni
you guys did your [ __ ] research uh if
it's cup and char
i'm okay with it but they use i mean
most most pepperoni makers use picnic
which is like little pieces of uh
it's like emulsified big pig parts like
no one uses
but uh but they use they use a cellulose
on the edge which is what why the
pepperoni comes in jars it uh
it shrinks when it heats up uh there's a
place called etso it's a farm out of uh
cleveland it's a
manufacturer out of cleveland they use
we're trash from the suburbs they used
better
cleveland uh
first of all he's talking about pizza i
was just talking about eating them yeah
we're talking about hormel oh i didn't
know you meant football snacks
i'm talking about what a pizza cheddar
yeah think about roll-ups baby
[ __ ] keto cause you like the [ __ ]
the one
the pizza you like real pepperoni yeah
that grows up but now
all right so there's a place called
bielsa uh in on
like not far from here actually they
charge 15 a pound for theirs it's
regulars
pepperoni it's like salami almost oh
[ __ ] so [ __ ] it they make it in-house
it's so [ __ ] good
love a good piece
i love when my hardened it just feels
like home you know
love it so what are your thoughts on the
hormel pepperoni it's fine
it's fine that's it if you charge me
more than 2.75 cents for a slice of
hormel on it we're having a problem
and it's going to be out loud okay how
do you save an avocado so you have say
you have a half of a
avocado in the morning how do you store
the second me
yeah you like your home alone squeeze a
lemon put it in a ziploc bag
is that happening though yes a hundred
percent when are you not using the whole
avocado because
if i'm saving the other half from my
wife yeah or he's also not an animal
because then it browns and even though
it's still good you just it just doesn't
look yeah yeah yeah yeah
dude when you open them up and they're
all black inside and like my girlfriend
tries to make me still eat it uh-uh i do
my wife will do it
tastes like i'm like they're a dollar
yeah i'll buy a hundred
yeah i got the patreon buddy we'll load
up the kia
i'm not i work too hard to eat bad
[ __ ] avocados off the jump for some
reason
avocados in new york that's the one
thing that really has a season like
there's a while where there's like a
two-week period where you gotta get it
and then you catch them in the winter if
they look like limes you're like that is
[ __ ]
great they come out you go to you go to
check if they're good and it's like
yeah you're like oh yeah do you ever get
because i i live in the heights so
there was like a shortage like it was
when there was a year out in mexico i
think it was maybe last summer yeah
there was something and the [ __ ]
cartels took over the avocado
and so there was a proper shortage and i
like kippy likes his avi
so i'm [ __ ] looking for him and
you're going to like bodegas and like
here
like you go to some place and they got a
couple do you ever i think it's the
florida ones it's the big green ones
yeah the massive something no no the
small ones oh yeah no these are these
are like
they're like the size of a volleyball
gmo joint
i'm like what i'm like you have avocados
he's like yeah here he's like
i'm like where are these the avengers
are making avocados yeah they're like
like the brontosaurus ribs or whatever
you know they're literally they're like
the size of your head i don't know if
you ever go to puerto rico like my uncle
brings them back they're this big they
look like
they look like uh like a weird bird
skull you know what i mean they're like
super long
i've never seen them they're crazy
they're they're odd looking um
okay avocado that's the classiest way to
save in avo yeah
oh you know what just eat the whole
[ __ ] thing yeah who are you kidding
um and when was the last time you had
yoohoo
oh god i love you because if it's been
in the past couple of years
you're trash oh no probably less than a
year ago actually 100
really less than a month ago
you who was great i actually tried
something called eminem milk
it's yuhu with uh peanut flavoring in it
where'd you get that
there's a like you buy it like pre-made
like in the bowdabra because bodega
sells like
weird [ __ ] from like europe and stuff
like random [ __ ] they find like how'd
you get that
they get it because it's all like
defected or yeah then it's past
expiration dates dude
peanut flavoring is basically like moldy
box you find in your grandmother's attic
it is disgusting yeah
it made me sick for like two days how
would you rate uh you know you're an
east coast guy
what would be your give me your top
three or four chocolate milks
one what are you doing was that in the
house when you were a kid
no chocolate milk was school chocolate
milk with school so like remember like
they would bring out the trays of milk
and everyone would get chocolate first
and then you get stuck with [ __ ]
whole milk like roses
was our brand and that was like the
locals we had clinton
clinton i didn't sound good no clinton
also made an iced tea
in the same place that distributed the
milk and
we would take the top and crunch it and
we would use that to kick around yeah
yeah you would whip kids with it like
the little kids it was [ __ ] great
it still tasted like medicine it was
horrific but everyone drank like four of
them
because nobody else wanted them but the
chocolate milk was clinton
and then if you go to the store now the
chocolate milk i drink now is that ron
berry farms order with the little
comes in a glass bottle talking about
yeah that's classy [ __ ]
oh dude there was no hershey's nah we
never did hershey's what about nesquik
were you and that's quick that's quick
powder
in the in the in the vanilla milk and if
you're good you get the little
the powdered chunks that stick together
you could chew they kind of float
how about next quick that's [ __ ]
bottom of the barrel
you want to hear trash my mom wouldn't
get cocoa pebbles so we put chocolate
milk in the regular pebbles the regular
pebbles into the in
cocoa but not cocoa pebbles whatever
fruity pebbles in a nest quick chocolate
milk
holy [ __ ] yeah trash fruity pebbles and
chocolate milk
that's disgusting but uh let's grab
email me the recipe please
hey that's gross but i'll have to
investigate further dude you know what i
did
the first time we got uh media passes to
mls cup it was in toronto in february it
was like freezing
and they brought us all into the media
hub and we're not real media we're not
asking real questions
and they had like coffee hot chocolate
and like those little boxes of cereal
and i was just so cold and so hungry
i took a boxes here and i go to get the
chocolate milk or like those
whatever and there and there was none
there was like hot cocoa there was none
so i was like what they just had the
powder they're like we're out of the
water so i was like and i had already
poured it over the cereal
so i just poured coffee into the thing
and i made
like a mocha coffee with cereal in it
and i'm eating it because i just needed
something that was hot and food at the
same time maybe we're not that far
and one of the other reporters is like
you know and he looks up and he's like
is that is there coffee in there i go
yeah and hot chocolate i was not meeting
zero
and i just realized this is why no one
talked to us for the rest of that trip
the yeah you're in there eating
condiments that's the lead story
dirtball from newark arrives in toronto
i'm like sucking down ketchup packets in
his mind
it makes him makes milk out of creamer
if you're the biggest dork at the
american soccer event
yeah oops i [ __ ] up
did you have a did you have a car when
you were in high school or anything like
that would you ever
ever ever whip nah but college i did i
had a 1992 mitsubishi diamante with the
radio buttons on the steering wheel and
you could i thought it was what's that
mitsubishi diamana it's
all of your [ __ ] trash all the
original [ __ ]
brut not bruce lee who's the guy that um
from like rush hour and all that
jackie chan yeah all the like old-school
japanese japanese jackie chan movies
which we would like watch all the best
that thing stung dude he those were like
lawyers cars in those movies in japan
so i thought i was king [ __ ] dude
mitsubishi like did japanese
italian guy unless it's a zero yeah
those things
diamond that's the eclipse
owns a fusion restaurant there was no
buddy look at the interior and look at
the steering wheel it had radio buttons
it's like a bad
it's their that's their avalon do you
know what i'm talking about they're
available it's not their camry the
gallon is the camry this is their avalon
this is like
uber drivers if this car was still
around this what they the fancy ones
would drive this this would be an uber
black
dude those things all right okay buddy
it's pure trash the thing used to spit
out oil that smelled like onions
it was disgusting did you ever put
anything any any aftermarket
uh any hugs any six by nines any sub
questions did you ever put the fake
bullet holes on the car
my step dad had those are you kidding me
no i put those on my mom's minivan
my car got stolen i ended up getting a
wrx after this car and it was a fast
cars nice one i had money at that time
uh and it got stolen three times third
time bullet holes were coming out of the
trunk
so i was like i don't want this car back
something bad happened in it i don't
want it back
so my mom gave me her old minivan it was
a 1992 plymouth voyager
the grill said dodge the radio said
chrysler and the trunk said
plymouth it was the [ __ ] battle repo
that's a real american car right there
you could take the key out of the
ignition while driving
oh my god i toss it to my friends in the
back
at one point my wife who was my
girlfriend at the time gets in and she's
like what this is disgusting
and my buddy was like yo switch with me
sit with my girl in the back so my
buddy's in the front seat his girls in
the back with my wife
and they're having this conversation
they're like this car is horrible and at
one point they moved the carpet and
she's like
i could see the highway yeah there was
like a big rust hole in it
i put bullet hole stickers all over that
[ __ ] thing to answer your original
question the diamante may or may not
have kid care subwoofers in the trunk
yeah they're getting subs in the trunk
in high school was
big this was college but here in the
trunk rather
my buddy had he he had a he had a cougar
like a 2002
cougar buddy like the real shitty ones
that had like a weird hatch batch
it was like european looking yeah they
tried to make it like fancy it was a
real piece it was a ford puma in europe
but he put a [ __ ]
uh he put like paying cars you ever see
a russian car you're like oh yeah
yeah the whole front opens up the wheels
on the roof
yeah this looks like two volvo fronts
welded together the whole car
yeah they're they're real they got real
geometric with this
no one designed the back this thing's
got two hoods
it's got four steering wheels yeah we
made
how many radiators does the thing have
where's the gas car
we didn't designed uh but my buddy had a
[ __ ] like a four thousand dollar
system in a [ __ ]
two thousand dollar car and the subs
they were like the jbl
like i mean he dropped every dime he had
into it and
every accessory dude every mirror shook
off the visor
shook off dude you just being there like
it's a good start you have to listen to
everything on nine yeah dude stop it
yeah trash dude i told you i'm basically
yeah yeah that's
tough um have you ever had your picture
taken on an extra large piece of
furniture such as a couch or a chair
yes oh man yes dude
for my 15th birthday my mom thought it
would be a good idea to get the photo
that that guy had in his house basically
it's me on like a big stupid [ __ ]
latin chair that kind of that we had to
take the plastic off of for the photo
because we used to put plastic on our
furniture
because we had two living rooms we had
the the nice one that no one said what
we call the living room in the family
room
bathroom was the knock-around room you
get caught in the living room
yeah yeah my whole family stood there
when i first started dating my wife and
watched her sit down and they're like
huh
we only unless we're opening christmas
gifts that's the only time we're allowed
to sit in that room that's fantastic
yeah
dude of course and i know your parents
are always trying to flex on somebody
when you're sitting in there i mean i
might like people would come over my mom
be like sitting in there reading a book
i'm what the [ __ ] you say
are you [ __ ] sitting here she's
reading the paper upside down
let me ask the second part the kippy's
question has that photo or a family
photo ever made it onto a t-shirt
that is all had no all right so we
didn't do like we had a small family
because of the the people that were here
so we never did like the cookouts or
family reunion no no but i did trash but
i was always so jealous
i did my i did want that photo to be
used if i was ever like murdered
or something as like the r.i.p shirt
like the airbrusher we all had
that's a kid from newark playing in his
[ __ ] airbrushed t-shirt we all had it
we all had it if i catch a stray yeah
this is what i want on the decal for the
back window god forbid
god forbid i can't destroy everyone's
god forbid that's great
um have you ever had your birthday at a
hibachi restaurant
no no not at all that got hot one time
when i was in like college or something
that was the thing that i don't know
i'm like i went there one time like this
i'm eating with these other [ __ ]
losers
the [ __ ] out of here the birthday person
has to catch the shrimp yeah you know
what are we doing we're talking the
community tables
yeah there's not a [ __ ] chance in
hell they tried to pull that on me down
to chinatown one time first of all
you're trash if you don't have enough
friends to fill that table
up yeah that's a big table nah it's just
the two of us
but there's a place down in chinatown
that's really good it's not woe hop it's
the one up the street
69 yard is it they have they have the
they have family style tape yeah yeah
yeah we didn't realize
that walking in it was just me and my
girl and we were like it was like a
bunch of [ __ ] businessmen from
belgium
i'm like i'm not eating with these
[ __ ] yeah
also if you do that all the young people
look at you like oh fat american let's
see what he's gonna eat
you're like a [ __ ] monkey behind a
fence your wife's feeding you
you're throwing me shrimp they're paying
for the meal no no bring more
more more lo mein we want to see this
guy yeah i'm not a family of the
community tables
growing up did you have a banana hook
like in your kitchen where you would
hang bananas off the hook
because if you did that's top-notch
clamps
the answer is yes and no i've never even
heard of that we had one like you hang
the bananas on a hook yeah
yeah it's like a paper towel holder kind
of we have one in our fruit bowl at home
it's still zip tied to the bottom of the
box
that's real true i don't even know what
you guys can picture it pull it up
because you know exactly what it is
you're gonna go oh [ __ ] he's talking
about the coat rack the guy who the guy
who
the hang bananas i don't know what you
mean are you talking about a basket that
hangs no it's like a little hook that
comes up like something like that
it's on the counter yeah oh i do know
what you're talking about yeah like that
where you hang your bananas we hung
plantains off of it of course
yeah so that's why yes and no we had one
but it was for platanos
do you do all right so i live in the i
live in the heights
big dominican food guys [ __ ] [ __ ]
best chicken in the world
i [ __ ] love it are people eating
plantains just you cooked them right or
people eating them raw
no like a banana yeah you got it you got
it you got it yeah but there's like
there's
if you're gonna start [ __ ] on
plantains no if you're gonna make a
little [ __ ] muffin gold
good night oh my god i like the sweet
ones a little bit of cheese on top and
they're all caramel oh buddy yeah let's
do it that's that's colombian
that's buddy let's go i'll eat plantains
all day but if you're gonna make
tostonas which are the hard ones that
don't that aren't sweet
you have to wait until you have to get
them pre-pre-pre-ripe
and then if you're gonna make the sweet
ones they gotta get ripe a little bit so
you hang it on that
to wait and when you start seeing the
black marks that's when you go make the
[ __ ] sweet
a thing of [ __ ] toast good [ __ ]
i heard about it one time i ate my order
my go to order when we go
is a thing of uh mufon go and then
tostones on the side
i eat like 19 plantains yeah that lady's
like this guy's got enough vitamin c to
kill him she's saying it right or is it
my fungo it is mofongo but i'm gonna let
it go
what did i say my phone goes you say
mofongo hello we would like two more
funky
dominican friend orders mofongo is
puerto rican mangu
is dominican but you can say mofongo
it's the same [ __ ] i don't know they all
say mofongo though yeah you could say
either or
it's also they're in new york you know
this guy's going to get us killed but yo
i'm not going to
there's a restaurant in in chicago that
makes the little totone
and they make sandwiches out of it
burrito yeah hibernito do it in chicago
there you go by the way they charge like
four or five dollars for these things we
used to make that growing that was like
our after school snack we would take the
food my grandmother cooked the night
before
i'm like damn they made a whole
restaurant of that what else did i make
i could make [ __ ] money
i was literally about to ask you whoever
had a hebrew they're great fire
yeah so good i love chicago food uh
okay burgers aren't that great there
everyone's flipping out how about this
you go out to dinner
uh you have a bottle of wine of course
you're taking the bottle of wine home
with you if you don't finish it
i'm not pure garbage you're kidding me
at least yeah gentlemen oh so who does
it feel ordered
yeah that's nuts i did it on sunday oh
my god came over i'm gonna cork that i
was like
yes i do throw some rolls in there isn't
it technically i got a solo cup i can
take for the wall
it's not illegal anymore it used to be
yeah they have to put it in a
like an evidence bag and seal it oh my
god
like duty-free i see your boarding pass
you want a free upgrade to the police
car
[Laughter]
have you ever been ghost hunting no
okay just check it you seem like a
straight shooter i'm just checking
everything else is kind of latin and
then that question i don't know
my i'm sure my aunts were all santa
[ __ ] so i'm technically i may have
been like you know [ __ ]
sir what's that called uh i was gonna
say circumcised that's definitely not
i'm not that but what's the
what's the back cut you're on the cut
cubing wow latinos yeah that's true
yeah hoodie all day uh what can brown do
for you
what's the thing it's not chilly in the
fall the girl spits this pee soup and
she's like
uh exorcist yeah exorcist i'm sure i
have one of those on me
yeah my dominican boy is dad's into like
what it uh you know all like what does
it say
yeah and he's like he's like i gotta go
for a run my dad needs a sweaty shirt of
mine to like boil i'm like
yeah great dude sounds [ __ ] stupid
keep that [ __ ] away from me they wear
the they wear the uh the breeds that's
how you know
yeah yeah i believe that i don't i don't
[ __ ] with the [ __ ]
i don't [ __ ] with black magic yeah i
keep it moving yeah it's either jesus or
nada for me
my buddies growing up where were haitian
and the one grandma was like yeah cuban
so you probably know santeria and i was
like santeria is [ __ ] and i said it
like that
and the whole family was just like they
thought i was going to get a strike down
mother
[ __ ] [ __ ] i mean i've always gone
after everybody
i've always been this guy as soon as i
learned english i'm like i'm going to be
a prick
you know it's like i'm good now um do
you enjoy any of the following smells
fresh fresh asphalt yeah in the
summertime it wasn't like that
buddy they just knew no no more potholes
let's go
gasoline yeah horses
no really yeah you like that i like the
smell of horses
i only the first horse i saw that didn't
have a cop on it was like i was like 28.
oh [ __ ] this one don't have a driver
what is there a riot
so had to this his driver you're at the
track who are they chasing
[Laughter]
dude jersey has the saddle racing
let me tell you never bet on the [ __ ]
chat guy [ __ ] zoom in
never put money on a [ __ ] chariot
having to screw you the races are too
long
have you been [ __ ] have you been to
the trotters yeah of course dude i grew
up in north jersey
two dollars a bet it's the [ __ ]
cheapest best and someone's like i got a
tip and you're like i'll listen to it i
end up betting on like the clydesdales i
never know
i always look at those guys the trotters
and i always said
that's not their real job this is a
part-time thing jockey that's a
full-time job there's no way these guys
are trotters are like
smoking burnies and [ __ ]
he's grabbing it like runners grab the
gatorade
dude i [ __ ] went to the aqueduct that
that uh casino in new york
like the middle of the hood yeah the
worst that every casino's in the middle
of it that's a good point
actually do they [ __ ] they have the
some guys like come on
come on i look up at the screen it's a
chariot race
from [ __ ] costa rica this guy hasn't
seen his kids in
years dude we did that all through
[ __ ] high school we started going at
like 15
16. yeah well we would go they have it
at they had the philadelphia racetrack
which would do live races on the weekend
we would do
and then uh during the week we would go
and just bet on the tvs like aqueduct at
[ __ ]
belmont like wherever they were running
races wow and the guy had the best line
he was like it was this old guy standing
up and he's got the [ __ ] paper and
he's like he's coming he's like betting
on the nine horses he's like he's coming
he's coming he's coming this whole
[ __ ] curmudgeon next to him he's
coming in his pants where he's going
i was like damn that's something this is
like a wednesday at one yeah yeah
wednesday at one and i'm 17.
that's true dude those are the guys what
do you want they had a show they'd have
the newspaper with the writing and the
on the edges yeah oh oh i'd always be
like reading it
we only bet on that well on the cool
names yeah you'd be like
this one's name here comes sunshine like
yeah let's let's do that i want though
shelter was the first [ __ ] the first
horse i ever won money on
first thing never worked out in my life
before she walked out on me dude you
could have had a kia back then you know
uh all right all right what do you guys
say sorry girl tv growing up do you have
a picture in picture
no we didn't i was having the other
night the [ __ ] thief
we
[Laughter]
yeah for a long time my friends would
make references to like you know
[ __ ] shows or something no simpsons
was fox i knew the national news
no they were talking about like
nickelodeon [ __ ] when i was growing up
i'm like what the [ __ ] like camp
salute your shorts and [ __ ] like i have
to salute you dude i used to [ __ ]
panic about like i can't see these shows
i don't get the references and i was
like i was always trying to be funny and
i'm like
if i don't know the references i gotta
[ __ ] you can't rip yeah i'm riffles
yeah yeah but did you see the weather
report for this weekend yeah yeah yeah
you want to talk about horses you guys
did you catch the six o'clock news last
night
give me your [ __ ] money i'm doing it
to him all right i got a couple from
patreon as you guys know
uh when you join the patreon we will ask
your garbage questions
we have a bit of a backlog but we're
getting to all of them thank you for
being patient y'all are the [ __ ] [ __ ]
salute your patreon by the way thank you
guys thank you
[Laughter]
i meant you and kippy we know the kid
tells us
how it is you get a haircut you lose
weight
you hit rogaine are you using jawed
robin
i knew it he insulted a top
restauranteur in new york city i think
he's going to come after us
said bourdain was overrated well cirque
more like
all right let's go ah
this one's great this one's just a
[ __ ] home run of a question this is
from
uh tony p have you ever owned your own
bowling shoes
yeah because if you are you're trash i
never got in a bowling thing
yeah never i stole a pair i think there
was a time in high school where i
thought i was going to make that a look
and i think i might have worn bowling
shoes for like a couple days in high
school
i think everybody a lot of dudes tried
to be like oh these are cool and happy
it was always someone who stole them
from a bowling yeah yeah like these are
ironically cool they kind of look cool
yeah yeah i had my own pool stick oh oh
that's fresh
how about you want to hear worse the
name of it my buddy got his own karaoke
mic
oh we had a karaoke machine no no he
bought a mic to bring to the karaoke bar
it was gold and
like silver on top could he sing well
kind of not
not gold mike worthy no this guy should
not have had his own mic it wasn't wayne
newton but
at the bar he's like you know what i
mean he's like brings his own mic plugs
and you know he did it long too
like people saw [ __ ] johnny's
breaking out the mic 100 and if the
other mike had nowhere to go he's like
does somebody want the regular mic
i brought my own uh i got mine who wants
to i'm not you yeah we had dance moves
it was embarrassing damn
karaoke's trash we would go just to
laugh at him it was great
but back to the pool queue yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so do you have a
name for it no i never gave it a name
but i purposely picked one that was like
had like some latin-like design it had
like the mexican carpet kind of designs
on it yeah so
like it would like you know yeah
and so my buddies all we all played pool
growing up like
all of us would hang out like like strip
joints during the day when they weren't
strip joints
and we'd always play pool like i knew
the code of like where to put quarters
and [ __ ] like i had the whole thing down
i rolled the stick before to see if it's
even like the whole night i'll do that
it's like it's also like the confidence
i have after making one ball on a pool
table dude the way i walk if i have to
turn the corner oh my god you become
paul newman i flipped my jacket
i'm going you hope someone opens the
door so the wind catches
the [ __ ] powder up like [ __ ] dude
i have my own [ __ ] technique for the
whole night
so i just got the pool stick i would
bring it dude i was such a [ __ ] nerd
by the way just for the record a strip
club that's not a strip club during the
day
garbage yeah okay yeah yeah yeah shout
out to the insurance office in the
afternoon
taste-tastics uh
all right a couple more here uh this
this is this is from turns
these are all history of people turns
out power butt power plug
r.i.p history yeah i know man i love you
so a great one
uh fantastic turns out plug power is in
blood but
whatever you know who you are uh is it
garbage to have a black toilet
yes yes do you ever see those no i feel
like i'm in a swinger's house any time
i've seen one italian people always
it's always italian black lacquer black
toilet with a gold
seat oh my god that's that's that's a
real gadget
that's peak any [ __ ] that is like the
epitome they like their marble those
those italians my step
my stepfather owns a construction
company yeah like that's what that is
like he gets
the good deal on yeah because nobody
else [ __ ] wants it everything in your
house it was like sitting
it was like their suppliers like i got
this laying around if you wanted to have
bro i'll take it yeah
black tiles
yeah it's true when there's too much
tile in the house it really sticks out
yeah yeah yeah it's like a meat locker
you
turn the [ __ ] heat up yeah you'll
hold the temperature the dog refuses to
walk because it's too slippery yeah put
it in the parthenon if you have a black
toilet you 100 call it a commode
oh yeah yeah yeah i'm going to hit the
commode if you had a black toilet before
cell phones you also had a phone
hooked up in the bathroom
that used to blow my mind a couple of
friends who had that
buddy i was in a i was in a the first
time was ever in a hotel that had a
separate room for the toilet in the
bathroom
it had a phone in there and i saw it and
i [ __ ] yelled out the d i'm like d
call the other because the extension i
call the extension and i [ __ ]
i used my elbow to kick it off and i
grabbed it i was like i you i might as
well be in a yacht
yeah sure yeah get me somebody anybody
yeah yeah
tell johnson to get his ass in here get
the new york times on the phone
yeah i said sell gizelle that that's
great i had a star tech that made me
feel like a doctor same feeling
what's a star tech remember the old clam
shell ones that would go on your
on your waist oh yeah yeah look it up
it's brown it had the battery like it
looked like a [ __ ]
it was the best way it was a cell phone
yeah jay-z had one and i had one that's
a
i stopped the list there yeah other
bunch of losers our first cell phone was
that was the was the big one
walkie-talkie yeah my dad had my dad had
the car phone that was like
was that the briefcase with the string
attached it was mounted
it was mounted you couldn't move it
buddy but it was like velcro
yeah like you could put it in the amount
they had the car phone in it
yeah it wasn't hooked up though you know
you know how hard i try to find someone
to hook it up because they just wouldn't
do it anymore
yeah but you know dope that would have
been [ __ ] i'm putting one in the kia
in 2005 to pick up a phone with the
[ __ ] curly string oh
buddy airstrike mogadishu
yeah i need a yacht in the mediterranean
all right let's do one more while we're
on the why we're on the [ __ ] topic of
cards this is from paige johnson
out there on a patreon uh have you ever
had a stuffed animal in your car
yeah cause we won it at a fair but you
left it in the car was it in the back
looking at the back window
man that's it pull the t-bone got it
pikachu staring at all the other cars
it's always like a turtle what are we
doing
anytime i would see a garfield i wanted
to drive them off the road
that was [ __ ] you know what else is
real shitty it was like uh the banana
with the jamaican hat that was a tough
look or like the little
the little chuck taylors or the little
jordans hanging over the mirror
oh my god boxing gloves with the puerto
rican flag
yeah i'm going to say i don't have the
numbers in fact
i had a cuban flag made out of beads
hanging from my uh rearview mirror out
of beads yeah the ones you would wear
around your neck you'd wear beads with
the
you would make them make the flag out of
beads
i'm just going to go ahead and close it
let me uh let me let me compute some
numbers here
divide that by two what does that come
out garbage
100 newark uh i refuse to accept that
i'm treasure garbage i am basura
yeah maybe in newark but in manhattan i
got the [ __ ] vespa outside you're
trash
uh do you validate parking and ant you
made it you may know your way around a
[ __ ] slice of za buddy
but you are garbagio [ __ ] the diamante
guerrero's over here buddy
the mitsubishi diy that was great alexis
carreras ladies and gentlemen
absolutely fantastic anything you want
the folks out there you got coming up
yeah i didn't plug it away
social media whatever uh follow me at
not alexis
uh on instagram and on twitter um and
you can follow at soccer cool against
s-o-c-c-e-r-c-o-o-l-i-g-a-n-s
it's a podcast it's a television show on
fubo if you don't have football go to
footballsportsnetwork.com
it's free streamed if you do have fubo
or if you want foobo
and you don't have it go to
footballtv.com i don't make any money on
that that's just for y'all
you get a longer trial and you get a
really big discount um it's basically an
entire cable system
that you could just carry around in your
pocket or on your tv whatever you want
it's dope and uh yeah just
listen to our show give us five stars
whatever all that stuff buy our merch
we got cool hats and [ __ ] fantastic
podcasts yeah yeah great if you like
soccer we're the ones for you 100
100 a hundo kp what do you got for him
guys as always please make sure you
review subscribe on itunes still in the
top 200 we appreciate that
[ __ ] patreon check that out that's
[ __ ] cooking the youtube numbers are
true to [ __ ] roof
uh we'll be at zaney's nashville and
raleigh good nights
at the end of april 25th those [ __ ]
tickets get the tickets
you can tell i got a little little hair
up my ass about this i want to see some
[ __ ] numbers moving in nashville
uh and then i'm at kevin ryan comedy on
all social media go
check it out adage foley and ice on
twitter and foleygrams on instagram
t-bone you got anything
yeah everybody go follow the podcast oh
yeah yeah
big fish circling make us look better
the social media don't reflect the
listenership
yeah toby just had a heart attack i'm
not big fish enough
you gotta leave that in that was perfect
oh wait a second
where the [ __ ] are you going sit right
back down don't touch that dial
and hear one more word about our good
friends over there on the stereo app
doesn't matter whether you have an
iphone or an android you can sign up for
free yeah guys come join the after party
i have a couple of beers i see
you know eddie and me it's a little
unfiltered you know what i mean fun it's
a good time me and the big man chopping
it up
answering your questions once a week
typically thursdays
use the link in the description
www.stereo.com
kevin ryan or slash h foley if you're a
fan of the big man
uh we get to let our beaks a little bit
it's a good time perfect way for you to
interact with us
we've gotten some home run of questions
on there too fantastic and a lot of
great shows
on the app as well that aren't ours yeah
a lot of good comedians if you're a fan
of comedy podcasts or on there so check
it out that's stereo dot com slash kevin
ryan slash h foley
peace